So, given this pipeline that was in the quiz, we found that B is the slow stage
here and B is, in fact, called the bottleneck. It's the slowest stage and it's
the one that determines how fast anything is going to come out of the pipeline.
And there's always a bottleneck in the pipeline. In fact, there's always some
slowest stage. Maybe two or three that are tied for slowest but there's always
some stage that's the slowest. Objects 3 and 4 move on through the pipeline and
object 2 is still being processed by B. So, what this is called is when stage C
is waiting for input and nothing's coming because we're waiting for B to finish,
that's called starvation. That's where C is not getting anything until B is
totally complete. On the other hand, what's happening here is stage A has
finished processing object 1 but object 1 can't move on because, stage B is
still processing object 2. This is called stalling. With the rendering pipeline,
these same sorts of principles apply. Having the application run efficiently and
keep the GPU fed with data is a common bottleneck for example. The bottleneck
will change over time. With sometimes one stage being the slowest sometimes
another. Gpu designers use different techniques to perform load balancing, such
as first in and first out queues. Where you sort of stack up a bunch of objects
so that if the stage suddenly gets faster, a bunch of objects can move into it
quickly, or other techniques such as unified shaders. We wont be describing
these techniques in detail in this course, but it's good to be aware that the
GPU has a lot going on inside of it. Various performance debugging tools let you
see what parts of the pipeline are bottlenecks and so, can help you improve the
performance of your application.